hell of a presidential race sir same
damn joke hell awake you Ana Barbara and
poor choices with security at
unprecedented levels this isn't just a
gathering of the world's most powerful
leaders it is the most protected event
on earth welcome to London mr. president
what's wrong
rather bugs the hell out of me has
decimated the British capital five of
the world's leaders are now dead the
American president
is unaccounted for to our friends in the
West back away
number six on a ten list what do you
want your president that's not going to
happen then every death from this moment
forward will be on your head
we have to find lock away before he
finds the president we're going to kill
him slowly and broadcast it live yeah
let me get a lot more than
all of the executors propaganda
you don't let them take me it comes to
it I want you to kill me that's an order
London is just the first stop
just imagine every major city
into chaos the president dies tonight
for those who threaten our freedom
America will rise up all right here we
go
I'm making mistake we will find you
and we will destroy you
Mike we're getting you out
three o'clock race right back
oh my god of via contour you listen that
Robbie thing before I didn't president
fainted